good morning let's try that one more
time good morning
very good so first of all for those that
have come in from abroad thank you for
making the journey welcome to Spain
beyond Oviedo at Valencia to everybody
else
welcome to the 2018 fiber-to-the-home
conference I think it was very apparent
they're listening to the minister the
pride that Spain has in the
infrastructure that it's built out over
the last number of years I think the
vision that we've seen being shown from
Spain's leadership but not only that as
the minister touched on as well the
vision that they've had with regards to
their regulatory policy has been hugely
important in allowing the operators to
then take that vision and to have the
courage to work with the investment
community to build out an infrastructure
in a time frame that almost seems
ridiculous if you think about it Spain
has gone from zero to hero status on the
European fiber-to-the-home penetration
scale in what feels like no time at all
if we think about how long we've been
building out fibre infrastructure's
across Europe it's a fantastic
achievement I think the vision and the
pride that we see here in Spain today
coupled with the venue that we have here
the city of Valencia the food the people
and you'll note we even booked the
weather for you
I think we're setting ourselves up to
have the best conference that we've ever
had so once again welcome to everybody
on the topic of visionaries society
needs future visionaries we need people
that can change the game that can alter
society that can elevate their vision
above what the naysayers say can't be
done it's absolutely critical that we
have those visionaries however it's not
uncommon for visionaries to predicate
their view based on past experiences so
what they predict for the future is what
they've seen before
and to use an analogy to try and
describe just how silly that sometimes
can be a friend of mine gave me a good
analogy there
see where he spoke about it's a little
bit like trying to give instruction to a
blindfolded driver of a car while you
look out the rear window as he drives it
all goes reasonably well so long as
there's no major changes or surprises
and that's one of the challenges that we
have quite often the visionaries that we
have that dictate you know when they're
asked questions about why do you need
fibre
who needs gigabit connectivity and we
hear these assertions that come from
people based on past experience and
unfortunately our industry is littered
with many many examples over the years I
have a few to share with you this
morning we take for example Sir William
priests chief engineer of the British
post office back in 1878 and Sir William
his views were very much cemented in
what had been working to date when he
was asked about what he thought of the
telephone this new innovation that was
coming from the Americas his response
was very clearly cemented in the past he
spoke about how the Americans have a
need for the telephone but we do not
we've got plenty of messenger boys
I wonder what Sir William would think of
today's modern communication world I
wonder how many messenger boys would be
needed to deal with the 500 million
tweets a day that Twitter deals with I
think it was a little bit short-sighted
possibly in his vision
another example is Ken Olsen president
chairman and CEO of Digital Equipment
Corporation or deque as they were known
for those of you that are old enough to
remember DAC they were the ones that
brought a real challenge to IBM in the
mainframe computer space and for the
record I'm not old enough to remember
them but I've read up on them and one of
the interesting things with Dec is
people often ask what happened how did
it all go wrong you know there was a
massive market available for them and
yet their demise happened very quickly
and to quote professor Clayton
Christensen of Harvard they got
disrupted they didn't spot the threat
that was coming to their business until
it was too late and then was they tried
to pivot true acquisition they had
already missed the market can at the
time was busy evangelizing to the
industry trying to convince them that
there was no reason anybody would want
to
computer would in their home now
personally I agree with Ken and I think
I'll talk about some of these topics
later on in the Hindi talk that I think
we will very rapidly transition away
from having that big lump of plastic and
glass taking up space and using power
within our homes but that's for
completely different reasons to what can
envisage at the time my favorite example
if you go back to the 1990s my now
brother-in-law who was an architect at
the time arrived home from work one day
he'd just taken receipt of a new
computer to help him with his job and he
was full of pride he was beaming he says
I just got this new computer today and
he was trying to sound exotic he says
it's called a Sun SPARC station this was
back in the time when I had an Epson 286
with one Meg of RAM and a 20 mag hard
drive 20 Meg you couldn't even fit one
photograph on that nowadays and he went
on to tell us about how all the software
comes on this disk called a cd-rom no
this was just before music CDs at John
mainstream and each CD ROM holds 640 Meg
of data to which you received the
response you see on the screen there
should not stupid who'd need that much
storage on their computer the person who
said that the person who said that was
me back in 1990 and the reason I give
that example it's very important to
remember that each and every one of you
probably have your own personal examples
of where we've been short-sighted with
regard to what we think is going to
happen in the future
and I think it's absolutely critical
that we remind ourselves when we're
questioning we see a new innovation
coming through we see a new breakthrough
in the technology that will allow tens
of gigabits in the future and we're gone
that's a stupid hooter need that we have
to remind ourselves there will be
applications that will come in the
future and take advantage of that we
don't have the gift of clairvoyance and
we shouldn't pretend that we do we can't
predict predict the future that said
today I will make a couple of
predictions of my own during the
presentation if we look at some of the
major trends that are happening one of
the big trends that's happening across
the industry and
across the Consumer Electronic space is
the shift towards the cloud augmentation
of everything open the left hand side
we've got the cloud they're trying to
articulate what was the overnight
success that took 20 years of software
as a service and software as a service
if we think about most of the software
that we use today most of the software
we take as a service from the cloud
it only has its full capability
available when we're connected some of
the software doesn't work at all unless
you're connected and that's the model as
we go forward in the future two days of
installing stuff on your local PC and
that's you dawn that's the end of the
commercial relationship those days are
over and they've been over for quite a
while we've got companies like toy talk
and toy talk is doing a really good
example of where they're taking
inanimate objects that our children play
with and our children learn with and
they're augmenting them with artificial
intelligence from the cloud so they've
become much more interactive and allow
our children to learn much much faster
open the top right hand side we all know
the robots are coming they're coming for
our jobs but the reality is when you see
robots like up on the right hand side
that's awesome Oh a NASA MOU is the
fruition of 20 years of research by the
Honda company very sophisticated robot
could make his way through this
environment and meet and greet people
and walk his way up the stairs etc the
challenge with awesomo is ASIMO carries
around a supercomputer on his back if
robots are ever going to make their way
into society and help our elderly and
clean our houses and do the ironing and
all the other jobs and trying to get rid
of if they're ever going to interact
that way we've got to democratize that
technology and the only way you can do
that is take that supercomputer that's
needed to give them the information and
calculate how they navigate their way
around and how they communicate with us
and to share it and to share it amongst
all the robotic devices there so we get
scale economies that go with that but in
order for that to work we need extremely
low latency an extremely high capacity
connectivity that only really fiber can
deliver you'll see out on the floor
there'll be lots of examples of virtual
reality augmented reality mixed reality
I prefer the phrase extended reality
because we're very rapidly moving
towards the scenario where it's all
going to come together all the $0.05
we'll be capable of being fooled as we
go forward by artificial stimulus
basically but if you think about the
impact of that the visuals that go with
it are gonna require extremely high
bandwidth and I'll talk about more about
that later on
but then when we think about things like
haptic feedback for a remote touch
control the latency requirements around
that are extremely challenging or if we
want to try and reduce nausea things
like jitter you know the latency needs
to be consistent but it also needs to be
very short as well and fiber is the best
solution to allow that to happen in a
remote fashion we're also seeing how the
world engages with compute technology
and how it accesses knowledge would
indeed within the cloud grid in the
internet is changing we're moving away
from the era that we all grew up with
where we engaged with compute resources
and we accessed information through
keyboards mice and screens we're now
moving into a world where voice control
is coming to the fore and I go so far as
to make the assertion that you know that
the children being born here in Spain
today will probably never master
keyboard skills because they'll speak to
the compute resources they'll use
gesture control to guide those resources
on what it is that they're trying to
achieve and if you look at the companies
that are backing that you've got the
biggest technology companies in the
world all over this pumping hundreds of
millions into it because they recognize
this is the future of search this is the
future of shopping this is the future of
how we engage but if I take away the
connectivity all of those things along
the bottom row of the screen are dumb as
bricks they don't work so we need very
reliable connectivity so I said I was
going to make a couple of predictions
today here's my first in the gigabit
society the need for the vast majority
of consumers to own a home computer will
disappear our means of engagement with
cloud-based information will transition
from keyboard medecine screen to voice
and gesture control along with mixed
reality displays so that's the first one
how we consume information is changing
as well traditionally we read
information and reading is an extremely
reliable means of distributing
information but unfortunately it's a
reasonably slow way of taking in
information for the engineers in the
room I trouble note with an example of
the likes of the Haynes manual the
engineers like to you know service their
own cars and that sort of thing and just
for the record I am a recovering
engineer myself so I can speak about
this with some degree of knowledge and
what we're seeing is I used the Haynes
example very deliberately because what
we're seeing is a massive shift in the
industry towards all knowledge being
disseminated through video there was a
recent repost by one of my fellow board
members and Tony from prism and Tony
wooden - Tony Bosh from prism within
that poster was up on LinkedIn there was
research done with regard to how
Generation Z how they learn how they
best learn in an environment how they
consume information and all I can say is
if it's not in video form forget it
you're not going to secure the mind
share of the youth that are growing up
today it's all about video and the one
thing that we can predict is that the
video is going to increase in richness
and it's going to increase in volume one
of the interesting things where video is
a fantastic medium for us all to learn
with it's also great for entertainment
as well and thanks to things like
YouTube and Vimeo the entrance barriers
for people bringing new video formats to
the fore or have never been lower we've
now seen new genres come true and have
massive success things that we never
would have dreamt would have gained
traction and certainly if it was left to
the big six production studios globally
they never would have made it to our
screens but thanks to YouTube etc we've
now got scenarios who in the audience
for example has children that are
addicted to unboxing channels
I remember my kids went through a phase
of that or the latest in our household
with my nine-year-old son his fails of
the week he loves nothing more than
watching people fall off their BMX and
hurt themselves I know there's some of
you out there are addicted to cat
channels you don't have to put your hand
up and reveal who you are I know you're
out there
but the reality is there's a
long tail of different video formats
gaining traction to very niche markets
out there and that tail is only going to
continue to get longer the media quality
is only going to increase
as we go up from 4k to a K and into the
future
we'll start to talk about things like
360 video we can already stream 360
video I think this session here has been
recorded in 360 video as well so this
stuff is starting to go mainstream
slowly but surely on the topic of screen
resolutions on the chart you probably
can't read the chart behind me very well
but really what it talks about is how
35% of european households would in the
next two years are gonna have an ultra
high def TV in the household and that's
important for planners one of the things
I often hear planners when they're
saying how much bandwidth are people
going to need they talk about you know
one 4k TV in the living room a couple of
high def TVs dotted around the place few
tablets and phones we say about 50 Meg's
that should cover it and they're so
wrong it's scary how wrong they are
if we think about the other trends that
are happening within the industry go
down to any of the high street
electronics stores and look at the
high-end tablets that are available
today
they've all got 4k screens built into
them all of the latest laptops and
desktop computers the screens are all 5k
resolution so when these devices stream
content they'll stream in much higher
resolutions than what people really
anticipate last year so this is a year
ago at Mobile World Congress Sony
introduced their premium phone handset
and that came with a 4k screen now you
might ask what do I need a 4k screen for
on a handset is that for a sharper
netflix experience it's not the reality
is the mobile gaming industry is worth
40 billion dollars a year 40 billion and
there's a massive genre coming to the
fore word in the mobile gaming industry
in the form of virtual reality those of
you that have tried virtual reality one
of the things that you'll realize very
quickly is that once you get over the
wow factor you're looking around going
oh this is fantastic it works really
well after a minute or two you get what
they've referred to as the screen door
effect it's like looking through an
insect screen you know to stop insects
flying into your home and the reason
being is because the resolution is very
low and the screen is right up to your
eyes the human eye sees and 12k
resolution
the headsets that are available today
the very leading edge within the mass
market today are typically at around 4k
resolution and in that scenario with 4k
when it's up that close to your eyes you
can still see all the pixels etc the
screen that I show up there that virtual
reality headset is by a company called
Vario they're a finnish company
delighted to see a european company
taken to charge here and they've
recognized the fact that the human eye
sees in 12k and they're taking the lead
in that they've created a headset that
can replicate that experience for the
users so now you're getting into an
environment when you do virtual reality
it actually feels real it feels like
you're in the room here you can't see
pixels anymore
think about the bandwidth that's going
to be required for that and that then
extends onto things like augmented
reality and mixed reality when we think
about those technologies we tend to
think about very basic graphic overlays
like somebody's name above their head or
turn-by-turn navigation but there's no
reason why that won't be every bit as
rich from a graphics perspective as what
we see in the virtual reality world so
my second prediction for today is the
need for ever-increasing broadband
capacity will continue indefinitely
underpinned by the increases in media
richness and screen quantities over the
coming decades anything that can be
augmented by a screen as we go forward
will be and it'll be a very
high-resolution screen as well one of
the things we need to think about within
the industry quite often we get
distracted by some of the sexier use
cases you know the autonomous vehicles
the connected cars etc and while they're
gonna have a massive impact on society
when they do arrive we also need to
think about some of the other things
that are gonna have a very large impact
things like you know Europe's
enterprises Europe's manufacturing
industry and the reality is you know
increasingly because of globalization we
have to compete on a global stage and
those companies that come out really
focus in on their core competencies what
makes their products better than the
next guys products the ones that really
don't bring their focus and allow them
to selves to get distracted by all the
things that are not core to their
business they're not gonna succeed in
the long term and to that end it's
absolutely critical that we need to be
thinking about
you know things like the IT
infrastructure that causes a lot of
destruction in many businesses today
thanks to increasingly ubiquitous fiber
connectivity particularly here in
countries like Spain in France and
Portugal and the Nordics we now have the
real capability to take those things
that are not core just like we don't
service our own vehicles anymore for
within our companies
likewise for that IT infrastructure to
move that to people that that is their
core competence the likes of the Amazon
Web Services of this world the Azores of
this world they their core competency is
running web scale high availability IT
infrastructure why should we let our
businesses get distracted from what we
should be focused on to ensure that
we're successful in the future
infrastructure as a service is only
really now becoming a reality because of
the increasing penetration of fiber out
there and as we get more fibre out there
that will become within reach of
everybody how we learn how we research
how we diagnose is improving all the
time the tools that we have available to
us now have never been better and those
tools as I mentioned earlier are
increasingly being augmented by
connectivity to the cloud those of you
who have kids in the room looking at the
demographic I suspect that's that's a
reasonable amount of us within the room
here we know we can't get away with
giving poor connectivity to our digital
native children in the future this will
be classed as a form of neglect
just like depriving children of
education if you deprive them of that
connectivity to the world that'll be
frowned upon within society those who
cannot access digital learning and
eHealth
they're going to be left behind versus
their peers on the global stage they're
gonna struggle to catch up the divides
in the future as we go forward will be
the divides between the digitally
impoverished versus the digitally
empowered today sometimes they don't
know if we get them here in Spain
certainly in the Irish market every so
often we'll hear ads on the radio trying
to encourage that very small percentage
of society that still are faced with
challenges around literacy to face their
fears and
learn how to read and write because it's
a life skill it's absolutely critical I
think in the future as we go forward
digital literacy will hear similar odds
for those few people that get left
behind
former Secretary of Defense Donald
Rumsfeld frequently spoke about known
knowns known unknowns and unknown
unknowns and in this world where we've
got very good predictability with regard
to population growth and population
location where people settle where they
grow their families etc with that
visibility doesn't it make a whole lot
of sense to plan for critical
infrastructures in advance if you
picture a scenario like what we've got
on the screen there where we've got a
major power outage across the city that
happens from time to time but could you
imagine that lasting for a week or a
month it'd be unthinkable right there'd
be civil unrest if that was left to be
the situation now picture those of us
with kids in the 8 to 18 bracket in our
house if we lost broadband connectivity
completely for a week or a month the
likelihood is they'd probably move out
maybe there's a cunning plan in there
actually to get rid of it recently I was
doing some ruder upgrades at home I was
changing out parts of the Wi-Fi
infrastructure and upgrading the
firmware on the Reuter and I had to go
through a number of reboots to get all
the changes I wanted it to take effect
to happen and I noticed the first couple
of times that I went Jewish that very
quickly I was getting the dad the Wi-Fi
is not working coming down to stares at
me says oh this is interesting
so as I went through it all I started to
time it and I went through about another
five or six reboots to get everything
the way I wanted the dawn and the
average time it talked from me when I
hit the reboot button on the software
interface for the computer to when I got
that dad the Wi-Fi is not working was 12
seconds 12 seconds the phone could be
broken for a month and they'd never
notice they think about it when we were
their age if we had no phone for a month
we would have been cut off from society
and this is very important because our
digital pipe now connects us to the rest
of the world
it's mission-critical and increasingly
so as we go forward so because we've got
very clear
ability of what is needed as we go
forward from a population perspective
things like water treatment facilities
things like hospital in A&E wards things
like education facilities things like
roads things like electricity some of
the things that the Minister spoke about
isn't it critically important we plan
for those but most importantly it's
critically important we plan for the
digital infrastructure that's going to
be needed to meet the needs of our
children and our grandchildren as we go
forward and I say most importantly
because you know sure if the electricity
goes out for a week or two that's hugely
serious and probably more important than
if the digital infrastructure goes out
because it's life impacting but the
digital infrastructure has the
capability to transform society to make
our economies run much more efficiently
to make our lives run much more
efficiently and efficiency as the world
population moves towards eight billion
is becoming an increasingly critical
topic for every single one of us but not
just us for our children and our
grandchildren and their children as we
go forward within Europe this targets to
drive efficiency there's targets to push
energy utilization down by 20% and the
digital infrastructure will underpin -
that will drive an awful lot of that
change as we go forward whether it's by
closer communication between vehicles as
we go forward
whether it's smart homes that stop
energy being wasted when we're not
around or the smart offices or whether
it's electrical generation that's only
turned on as and when it's needed and
where it's needed and turned off very
very quickly accordingly I once heard a
statistic there recently where somebody
was saying up to 60% of energy produced
is wasted because they don't have enough
control on that and building a
fiber-rich society will allow them to
avoid that picture a city congested with
traffic one of the statistics that
floats around is typically at any given
time up to 30% of those vehicles they're
looking for parking so 30% are adding to
the problems you took 30% off the road
you probably wouldn't have the traffic
in the first place but picture in the
future as we go forward if true cloud
connectivity artificial intelligence and
ubiquitous wireless coverage
that is connected to a very low latency
high reliability fiber infrastructure we
could guide those vehicles proactively
based on where they're trying to get to
to the nearest available parking space
and only if inefficiencies that exist
without begin to disappear
think about if we could take our goods
transport industry and we could start to
pontoon vehicles together just like what
we do with trains today we all know the
aerodynamic efficiencies that go with
trains versus individual trucks on a
road but what if I could drive nonstop
from one end of Europe to the other at a
constant speed not speeding up not
slowing down how much more efficient
would that be from an energy utilization
point of view but in order to do that
you have to think about the connectivity
the connectivity between the trucks the
connectivity between the trucks and all
the other vehicles on the road all of
the traffic light signals along the
journey the railway crossings that they
have to try to cross over etc in order
to realize that vision massive
densification and wireless
infrastructure is going to be required
and to the minister's point without that
massive densification and fiber
infrastructure to backhaul all that
Wireless simply not going to happen
think about it today how many of you in
the audience today 45 years after the
first mobile phone call was made today
still can't drive from your home to your
office and make a call without a
dropping along the way and thankfully
those figures are improving but I'm
pretty sure there's still a number of
you out there that are in that situation
that you're running through black spots
all the time massive densification is
required if we're ever going to achieve
that densification we need to change
your attitude with regards to the
investment community the investment
community of no shortage of
opportunities of things that they can
invest in European telecoms market is
just one of them and if we sit there and
we get greedy about it and say oh well
we're not really willing to put in place
you know the regulatory environments to
give them certainty on investment and we
only want them to have you know a
certain return on that they'll just go
off to one of the other opportunities
that they have available and if those
funds don't come into our market the
infrastructures will not get built so we
have to change our mindset with that we
have to think about rewarding those that
are willing to make the investments
needed to deliver the fiber
densification that's required that will
allow things like the 5 G's of this
world to happen my third prediction for
today despite the assertions that we
will never achieve the full fiber goal
this will be achieved the ever
accelerating pace of innovation coupled
with the cloud augmentation of
everything
we'll see fiber prevail as the sensible
choice for the astute investor we have
to think about it like an ecosystem the
fiber is the soil it's the roots from
which everything is going to grow in the
future
without fiber there will be no 5g I'll
put that up there as one of the
predictions you know that's that's not a
light assertion that I make if we don't
get massive fiber densification all of
the visions that go with 5g all of those
use cases we've all heard about will not
happen without fiber our factories will
continue to underperform versus their
peers on a global stage make no mistake
about it the European economy is in
decline versus its peers on the global
stage and we need to correct that we
need to take some serious action to turn
that around without fiber our rural
communities will continue to have to
offer up their best and their brightest
to the cities because they can't get
work in their hometowns where they grow
up we need to change that how long are
we willing to face being digitally
impoverished five years 10 15 20 we need
to change it right here and now and
thankfully there is change occurring
within Europe we're seeing examples of
people who've taken an early lead and
are really driving that change if we
look at the examples like the Nordics if
you look at Portugal we look at Spain
where we are here now France is getting
on board with heaven forbid even the UK
now is starting to make all the right
signals and just while I'm on that topic
for the fiber-to-the-home council I'm
delighted to see that we now have today
we got permission last night
to announce that one of our newest
members who's just joined as one of the
operators from the UK so welcome on
board to city firebrand Greg and the
team I know you're in there somewhere
welcome on board congratulations I
firmly believe that those in vast who
invest heavily in the fiber
infrastructure they're going to be the
first ones to benefit from 5g they're
going to be the first ones to benefit
from things like autonomous vehicles and
e-learning etc they're going to be the
ones who will understand what it's like
to live in a fiber rich 5g enabled smart
City and they're going to be the ones
that are going to see a flurry of
startup companies emerge that can take
advantage of that take advantage of that
early knowledge and set themselves apart
on the global stage
we can't afford u-turns with this
ubiquity is key there's no point in us
having a patchwork of connectivity if I
you know if I if my monitor at health
only works in one state and doesn't work
in another
if the pond tuning trucks can only go in
one country but not across borders it
all falls apart really quickly the
business cases don't work it has to be
ubiquitous we can't afford short-term
thinking with this we can't afford
short-term investment with it we can't
afford u-turns it's too late if you're
planning for a problem that's already
here and now in front of you you need to
be planning well in the head going back
to Rumsfeld that we touched on earlier
where he spoke about the known knowns
there's enough known knowns in front of
us today if we're to avoid scenes like
this where people clamber over each
other in search of the elusive 5g signal
in the future sorry I couldn't resist
now all joking aside though 5g IOT
extended reality these are all known
knowns today okay how much fiber
infrastructure do we need even just to
make them happen now how many of you in
the audience would have predicted the
pokemons go could go from zero to 50
million simultaneous users in 12 days
none of you including me okay it's the
unknown unknowns that we need to be
planning for and that's where fibre
comes into play fibre is the only
medium that can allow us to scale when
we need to scale it's the only one that
will allow us to climb and to reach
those new heights so I'll close with
this we can provide all the
recommendations we want we can provide
all the use cases and case studies the
challenge regard is if local governments
will not recognize the fiber
densification absolutely needs to happen
if they're not willing to face down
those seeking to preserve the status quo
if they will not lead their countries
towards a future of digital abundance
they are sentencing their citizens to a
life of being a second-class digital
citizen on the global stage whenever I
hear when I go out and meet customers
etc and whenever I hear the stories
about how people in country x y&z for
discretion reasons they're very frugal
they'll only buy the bandwidth that they
need they've no need for gigabit they've
no need for fiber connectivity the
immediate response that screams out in
my head is where is the leadership think
about Steve Jobs Steve Jobs often was
quoted as saying you can't ask the
consumers what they want they can't
imagine it you have to show them and
it's only then when you showed them they
realize oh wow that's cool I really love
that and then he's held up as a hero for
bringing these products to market and
it's the exact same situation with full
fiber the other 98% of the population
that's not here today they can't imagine
what this new capability will bring for
them and that's where we have to guide
them that's where the industry has to
provide leadership that's where the
politicians have to provide leadership
full fiber starts locally the EU
Commission the local governments the
national regulators they have a duty of
care David Judy a care to you to you to
you to all of you up there to ensure
that you your children your
grandchildren do not become the
digitally impoverished as we go forward
into the future
every single one of you has a
responsibility to work within your
communities to drive awareness about the
importance of this created critical
infrastructure give it
Judea carry ourselves to push your local
politicians and to push your
parliamentarians within Europe to ensure
that they're demanding nothing less then
you have the infrastructure that will
allow you and your family to become the
digitally empowered as we go forward
muchas gracias enjoy Valencia and enjoy
the conference thank you very much